nueva yor ha amanecido castigada por
estas fuertes lluvias anoche como decía
y se suspendieron los servicios de metro
por fuertes inundaciones y esta mañana a
primera hora poco a poco se han ido
recuperando pero todavía queda mucha
gente atascada en las estaciones de
metro desde ayer por la noche y es que
como sabéis aquí el metro es la columna
vertebral de la ciudad más de 6 millones
de personas lo utilizan cada día con lo
cual el hecho de que se inundaba provocó
muchos problemas en la ciudad seguimos
todavía bajo alerta que se mantendrá
hacia aproximadamente la media mañana y
las autoridades han aconsejado que
evitemos en la medida de lo posible
salir con nuestros vehículos porque
todavía hay muchas carreteras cortadas
hay muchos destrozos hay calles que
todavía continúan inundadas y aunque
aquí veáis que esta zona está más seca
para que os hagáis una idea el central
park se han recogido lluvias de hasta 10
centímetros así que poquito a poco se va
recuperando la normalidad no olvidemos
que hace dos semanas ya vimos los
efectos de la tormenta henri así que
llueve sobre mojado no me ni qué se sabe
de los fallecidos y de los damnificados
cómo va el rumbo de la tormenta
si son nueve las personas fallecidas
angela siete de ellas en nueva york como
decía es hay que lamentar la muerte
también de un niño de dos años casi
todas ellas fallecieron en sus casas que
quedaron completamente anegadas por el
agua muchos días en la zona de queens
hay más de 200.000 personas sin
suministro eléctrico en el área
tri-estatal que eso incluye pensilvania
nueva jersey nueva york porque como
decías nadie se esperaba esta tormenta
es la primera vez en la historia de esta
ciudad que el servicio metereológico
emite una alerta por inundaciones
repentinas así que poco a poco se va
recuperando la normalidad hasta las 10
de la mañana se mantendrá esa alerta ese
estado de emergencia y las autoridades
han dicho que se espera recuperar la
completa normalidad a última hora de la
noche o ya mañana por la mañana eso sí
esperamos un fin de semana de sol y la
tormenta se dirige ahora hacia boston
que es allí donde podría haber
inundaciones en las próximas horas